If you're a fan of Eric Thomas and you're looking for ways to go get it develop a routine and change your environment
Then this video is for you and the reason why you are not where you want to be
You want to be a ten and you were running with sixes everyday you hanging around fives every day
When I was growing up it was a long long time ago
but we used to fight used to get in a circle forgetting a circle and then two people would get in the middle and
Then you'd fight some of you are not successful today because you do not have a routine and why's a routine so important?
Your routine will show you your gaps. What's that believe nation?
It's Evan my one word is believe and I believe in you I believe you have an amazing gift
Inside you that. I want to see explode out into the world
I started the mentor me series to try to learn from people who've done a lot more than us and hopefully
By hanging around them a little bit longer some of their beliefs
Mindsets way of thinking seeps into us to help us become the best version of ourselves so today
We're going to learn from one of the best Eric Thomas and some of his best motivation for 2018 mentor me Eric
You
Just what I want y'all to do tonight tonight, I want to go
I want to go somewhere because I told you you know like I don't know if you maybe because you're a human and
You've gotten so accustomed to human that maybe you don't know what you're capable of doing as a human, right?
Anybody get a new phone when you get a new phone
But the iPhone 7 8 right the iPhone or you went to the galaxy when you get that a Christmas or you get that gadget?
When you first open up that gadget? What are you? What are you happy about?
What it can do all the stuff it can do?
Right if you like a geek. I'm not a geek right, but I imagine the viewer gig you're going through life
I only use the stuff
I need like I like everything to stick and the other stuff, right
But the geeks know everything you can do let's do me very closely
I believe that some of us have gotten so caught up with school and work you forgot what you can do as a human
Like really you just forgot like you so caught up on life and problems
You're so caught up on paying bills you forgot you human
You forgot you - what made up the phone you made up the TV. You've made up cars
You made up fly like that human we fine a hundred years ago
They would have told me I could like we could fly to Australia and watch TV you watch a TV
Oh, we watch the TV on the with Australian
This is this is what happens when you add wild thoughts
And that's why what's all about tonight like wild thoughts like wild thoughts like like
I don't want you to be in school
For grades because I told you are we past that and that's why school is so hard for some of you
That's why I like it so hard for some of you because that's all you doing his life. Are you having a wild thoughts?
No more you don't dream crazy. No more. You kind of settled into like whatever little life
They gave you whatever a check they gave you
Whatever they told you to do for 40 hours like you locked in on that and I just want you to do yourself a favor
Maybe the weekend when you're not busy
I just want you to start touching the buttons and see what you came aboard I want you to get out of the average thinking
and look
I'm gonna get your secret
I want you to start having a wild thought
Because here's the deal
If you have wild thoughts
And they don't work out you can always go back to average thought the whole bunch of people waiting for you when you come back
I'll probably shoot. They wait me good average is gonna
Be there
So just do me a favor just start thinking crazy and wild I want to own multiple homes and multiple cars
I want to have that nonprofit. I'm gonna have that profit and I'm gonna be able to travel the world I'm gonna whatever
Okay, raise your hands. I'm telling the truth. You are crazy stupid talented. You know you are
But you get stuck on average not using your full potential MCA just some stuff
You know you could be doing this you ain't doing them you CA
You know you could be doing hands down listen to me real quick Eric Thomas
I don't really know who I am but you here tonight right so. I'm telling you
I'm giving you full permission to start to have a wildest dream to be yourself. I'm giving you permission. It's not waiting on people
It's the weirdest thing
I mean some of the most talented smartest people in the world who stuck because they waiting for it
I gave you permission. I give you permission to be yourself like I'm give me my why do I have the authority cuz I'm myself
So I'm with full Eric Thomas permission. I asked no other motivational speaker was it alright to go hip-hop
I'm just doing what I know I've been called a dude
unapologetically I
Wanna make sure I say that I ain't even know if I can say it
I just tried to see if I could say it I was in my head
I was like can I say that word I just said it it came out. You don't have to apologize to anybody to be great
You don't owe it to anybody else to play little no more come on
Don't play little no more like you don't want your brother to feel bad
Or you don't want your cousin to look you have full permission
You don't want your parents to think you will know it all you have full permission to be your
Greatness right now you have full permission
To be your greatness whoever you whatever your greatness is you have full permission to be that right this second
Anybody else been watching the Olympics especially track and field over the last like 20 30 years who dominated and track and field?
Whoo
USA dominated you had Carl Lewis
Michael Johnson Michael Johnson came with the gold shoes off
I'm just trying to let y'all know ain't nobody in the Gulf with the USA
Her sir was there. They was murdering them
And all of a sudden something happened look. Ya'll think I'm talking about him, and I'm not I'm not dealing with him
I'm telling you the environment you're in
It's so important look this guy this guy is not only the murder in the field, but what happened was oh?
Man he murdered the field he don't compete he dominates
But what he did for Jamaica was not freeing a gold medal. He brought a culture to Jamaica
He didn't bring a championship home. He brought a culture home chica
I gotta help you
Let me explain something to you so you an America and they're sending you that this this this is his this is his record
So theoretically you know how fast he is
Come on you hear me
Theoretically, you know how fast get so what you're doing when you practice. It is you try to beat his time theoretically I?
Need you to hear what I'm saying. This is why you need to be in an environment
Because theoretically they told you how quick you need to be and so you'd race
And then you look at the clock and coaches say you missed it
All right try again. Can you try again, and you missed it, but over in Jamaica?
It went racing against a theoretical clock
They took we can't gold medalist and dominate it because they was running against the real thing every single
Did you retreat what I said they were run against the clock they worried in their mind saying okay?
How fast did I go coach?
How fast I go then we run against the fastest men in the world so they knew how fast they're going
Let the to me and the reason why you are not where you want to be
You want to be a ten and you are running with sixes every day you hanging around fives every day
So people you talk on the phone to five and if you became a 10 they hate you so much
That you're afraid to be a 10 cos you're going to lose them you
Hanging around scrubs
And when you start winning all you do is win and some of you were losers and all you need to do is start hanging
With some winners, and you're gonna see when it and it's gonna spill over on you, but I was growing up
It was a long long time ago, but we used to fight we should get in a circle
Forgetting a circle and then two people would get in the middle
And then you'd fight right and I got smart cuz I really liked to fight
So I got smart and I started telling guys who said they wanted to fight me. I'd say look. Let's do this
let's not fight in front of nobody if you really want to fight us going to back just meet you I
Don't know why you clown in front everybody why you gotta try to be the big, man
let's just mean you go to the back and let's just fight and don't nobody go if you really want to fight and
I learn ET if you want to get out of fights in the D
the more you run the more they don't want to fight you but
The more you step up and say yo you want you
So I'm telling you in life you start running from a class
You start running from a subject that you don't like it will haunt you for the rest of your natural life
It ain't going away, but if you go after the fight if you approach the challenge you have a much better chance of winning
Those of you who are you you are like those dogs you have the potential you could possibly take him down you kind of
Kind of you know like I think I could get him
I think I'm not sure I think I can and then you watch the pitbull
And the pitbull can't notice it was no deferred the dogs hid in the back
They get the tail they going on the side they gonna come in the front when the pitbull can't even just came right oh
Okay right to the face Oh
And so I'm challenging you before you leave it's gonna be a fight
You can't keep doing this, but maybe your freshman here, maybe your sophomore year
but at some point
You got to go take the life out of it at some point you just gotta
I was owner took me 12 years to get the 4-year degree and the master's I was like and somebody said get the pen senile
I know there's like come on
He gets busy
And when I just start going after light and take anybody's throat not getting to the summon y'all get to the line
They got to the done the dogs got to the wild boar they got to you get you get real close the pitbulls was like
in game
They started with in game
There wasn't no going back and forth they came in whoo and all that time
He was standing up all I tell him to chase, but when the pit bull came and boom lockdown
You got to take that thing out like you got to take the breath out so some of y'all
I pray the math go after it
Go get it
Don't run from it no more
Don't get it
So I'm constantly doing my research to find out how do I help the Millennial Generation?
Right I was watching one of my homeboys speak right he's phenomenal. I was born in about the wrong way
I've been to my execution is March if
I've been on there execution is worship. You got to execute you got to execute
We're speaking two different languages what he shared with me is this is the generation of trying?
Like in your generation you get brownie points for trying
So what you do is you do selfies that ain't real, and so I didn't get it y'all get actual credit
But trying to look like you got it together like some kind of way. Will you take a selfie even though?
You've done absolutely nothing you literally do a selfie, and you get cred
You'll get a street cred for that like you get you can well you wouldn't be doing it
And so you put on your makeup and you get into place?
And then you make it let you do it eight times
And then you get the right one and you put it up and you drop a filter on it
And you get credit for that see the reason why I've been so hard on y'all is
Because where I come from and I used to watch the people on my block go to for GM and Chrysler
They wouldn't get credit for self. You didn't get credit today check there
It was on the line once and then he did it for 40 hours didn't they get a check
They weren't blessed to get credit for trying. I'm sorry it ain't so far
We live in a generation now where you get a trophy for just showing up
It's not that far you play on the football team y'all didn't win one game, but you get a trophy in two here
You get a job. You know we don't want hurt your feelings. Are you hear what I'm saying
I want to rewire you the problem that you're having is that you're looking for rewards when you just show up
And you think of somebody should be grateful that you showed up
I
Want to show you I want to show you what Bruce Lee said a long time a book so you don't take offense to it
No, one is not enough. We must apply
Execute okay. He didn't say no one is not enough you must try
It's not what he's saying
He was probably one of the best that ever do what he did
Willing is not enough. We must do you do not I cannot try to pay my mortgage
I cannot try to help my wife quit her job. I cannot try to pay my kids go to school
I can't go to Michigan State and say I want to try to pay tuition this money
They're gonna say okay? We won't try to teach your kids
We're gonna try to put him in the door
Gonna, try there with me knowing
again knowing
Come on knowing
We must apply Wheeling is not enough. We must we must
Every single day if you do what you say you're gonna
Do you're gonna get what you dream to get I need you to be honest do an honest assessment
And I want you to write down what it is you trying to do
And I need you to be very honest about where you are in terms of what you're trying to do like
Where are you so for those of you who like I want to be a millionaire?
I just need you to really be like think through. Where are you financially?
Like in terms of financial literacy. Where are you in terms of financial discipline? Where are you and in your past?
Where are you? Do you spend money? You don't have
So I heard somebody said Saturday. I thought it was fun right somebody was talking about and at this time time
I'm in Thailand you try to hear me. Can you can you lift your own weights, right?
Can you your own weight so somebody would say like yo?
I don't know why you're all on the phone all
Proud of the fact that you could change your own oil like why would you want to change your oil anyway? That's not your job
Right and somebody was like well. I saved 140 dollars
He likes save one hundred and forty dollars
But what have you make two hundred and fifty dollars an hour no hear what I'm saying
Why would you change your own oil to save 140 dollars when it took you three hours to do it?
And somebody like yo, so you said you always as I said look let me jump in like I ain't trying to be disrespectful
But first of all I didn't go to school to change oil
That ain't my job, that's somebody's job let my man
Do his job somebody else said that when he changed your oil because he went to school
There's some other stuff under the engine that he's see that you don't see when you change the oil
So y-you saved 140 dollars you missed something else that he would have helped you catch so that the life of your car, so
You changed your oil, but you didn't notice the three or four the things that was missing
And I said look let's not talk about you saving 140. Here's the challenge you can't pull your own weight
The challenge is you shouldn't have a car that costs you a hundred and forty dollars to change the oil
when you ain't got a husband forty thousand days or
You should have that car in the first place
Why do you have a vehicle that the oil costs 140 and you can't afford it?
Why would you buy something that you got to change the oil that's not your job?
and you know why you're doing it because it's no longer a car to you - a status symbol and
So we're dealing with something deeper you can't hold your own way you bought something you can't afford why?
The deeper issues because you got a self-esteem problem
and
So you got shortcuts so you drive a car to make it look like you somewhere you are
But when you actually there, you ain't gotta have a car that look like you there cuz you there
No hear what? I just said when you're there you don't have to look like you there there
But when you're not there you can't pick your own weight up you have to do stuff
and now you didn't messed up your whole credit because you bought a car so that people can think in somewhere that you not and
You've destroyed your whole future
Then if you could hold your own way you could drive around the Ford Fusion and be some tombow
Comfort like like a ranger you getting out that joy like a Range Rover
You getting out the Ford Fusion like what like you in a 7:45 a lot like what?
Why because you ready are you here B you ready, I'm running I'm running a mile a day
Walking at least amount of day
I might do five or six
But I'm committing to one a day for a hundred days
One mile walk a day a hundred days and a set of a hundred push-ups a hundred days
Are you hearing me out like a routine?
Some of you are not successful today because you do not have a routine and why's a routine is so important?
Your routine will show you your gaps
You know routine to show you your gaps you think vegan is just about eating right?
Vegan is showing me how disciplined? I am and how disciplined. I'm not I was murdering the gout look
I've murdered the game at the cria. Why cuz my cousin got everything prepared
but I learned a lot about myself when I get on the road I
Learned that I was probably like
6040 vegan on the road 60 vegan on the road forty vegetarian
Yeah
Yep, I realized when I got on the road
It's easy to win at the crib because everything is set up for me, but when I get on the road. That's a different monster
Every city don't have whatever so when I went to Chicago. I had to pack my stuff and take it with me
Are you not hear what I'm saying. I was on if I was on up 40% 30%
vegetarian why because when I get on the road I ain't got all my stuff I wasn't and so what I realized was like y'all
Eat you do good at home cuz somebody else prepares for you
You don't do as well as only when you on the road
Why because you don't prepare for yourself so as long as somebody's prepared for you?
You got to discipline to eat right, but your your strength is not in your preparation
And I saw a weakness in my preparation
That I got to work on a 20-18 if you're gonna do what you say you're gonna do people
You say you're gonna be you're gonna have to line me out that gazelle stop
I'm trying to tell you you a gazelle you gonna come up short
You were gazelle you're not always gonna get what you want out of life you a gazelle it's gonna
Be even have an average experience you a student. I need you in lion mode you a teacher
I need you in line mode you an entrepreneur. I need you in line mode you try to lose weight
Lion mode you can do nothing significant in gazelle mode nothing
Nothing impressive happens in gazelle mode. Nothing happening when you run it
Nothing happening run mode give up mold quit mold scared mode fearful more nothing happens
Everything that happened in line mode like I'm coming to get you
I love y'all obviously the one with a lioness is kind of sitting there
and she double-dutch it and all the Beast is running by and they just keep going and
She just in preparation mode and out of nowhere. There is no no music no no preparation
You just see my man come out of nowhere and just boom Bob grab one who?
Will rip your heart out. That's lion mode, and you got to get to a place. Will you start executing somebody just help me out?
Last year the greatest news in the NBA
The greatest story in the NBA last year was what play the story told in the NBA last year
Offseason was what Kevin Durant left go to go to state?
Durant like I'm out I don't know where y'all come from but that hurt our because they supposed to be boys
Look at this picture for a minute because this one if you're gonna be successful this where I need you to go right here
What a bitch this was the one where you play your boy first game you and your homie was cool
Right and this is where you emotionally cut it
This when you cut my man, this is when you see my man, and he's trying to be cool
He's trying to act like he leave you high and dry he tried to act like the goals in the dreams
Y'all have this the one where he clap it, and you look my man this place and say you get it to me
And that's what most of you will never be successful
Cuz there's some stuff in your past you keep holding on key, and you got to get to a point when you read it
Right and you ready to get to the next level you look at people used to be cause for say you dead to me
You did
42 triple doubles we shouldn't even be talking about the MVP
Ain't nobody else keep it somebody make it close to the MVP the NBA is rigged and I'm through with him
Hey summer, man beginning to see them come up
I'm to my height, and they said if he keep doing that all season what's will happen
They said he keep running him stuff like that. He's gonna burn out my man ain't burnt out
He look like in close to burn out
But you know why they said it cuz they can't operate in that level for that long
So people were trying to put they limitations on you. I can I can do six kids
I can do something we can leave here tonight. It would take me to a church
I give you another hour you can't do it. Don't put your limitations on me. I'm dead to your limitations your limitations
Don't exist in my world
Your limitations keep them. Don't watch them on TV
Go home read the newspaper, but go home and look in the mirror go home
Call your homeboy, and y'all talk about your lemon taste
I got nothing I get off the plane from bored through you buy and get on the crime
And I hate it and some of y'all hold on the stuff you should be holding on to it should be dancing now
I'm gonna go to a funeral if you need to get rid of that junk like Barry you have you got to do
But it's weighing. You know it's killing you every day you waking up thinking about it. You shouldn't be thinking about it
No more it should be dead to you move on
And move towards your grave. I forget those things which are behind, and I pressed I
Pressed hard you think I pressed. I don't got time for that no more. It's not personal. I got nothing against you
I don't ain't you but I love me
Thank you guys so much for watching. I hope you enjoyed
I love to know what did you learn from this video that you're going to immediately apply?
Somehow to your life or to your business leave it down the comments below
I'm really curious to find out I also want to give a quick shout out to shot in thank you so much for picking up
A copy of my book your one word and doing the review on your YouTube channel
I really really appreciate the support, and I'm so glad you enjoyed my so thank you guys again for watching
I believe in you. I hope you continue to believe in yourself, and whatever you're on where it is much love
I'll see you soon raise your standard
apple at the core its core value
Is that?
that people passion and
Now one drop of most self-worth depends on your discipline to me. I don't ever give up. I'd have to be
Dead or completely incapacitated. Hey believe nation if you want to see my all-time
Favorite top ten roaster success. I have a very special secret video for you
These are the individual clips that I have personally learned the most from and applied to my life and my business
Check the link in description for details